♪ ♪
>> Laura: OKAY, WHO IS EXACTLY
BEHIND PROMOTING THESE
OCCUPATIONS AND PROTESTS AGAINST
JUDGE KAVANAUGH?
WE HAVE AN "INGRAHAM ANGLE"
INVESTIGATION FOR YOU TONIGHT.
THE WOMEN'S MARCH UP AND AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE ANTI-TRUMP
MOVEMENT, AS WE ALL KNOW, AND
ARE TAKING THE LEAD NOW, STATING
JUST TODAY, JUST "WE ARE
ORGANIZING IN A TACTFUL, AND ON
ARREST, DIRECT ACTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE SENATE KNOWS
THAT WE BELIEVE CHRISTINE AND
DEMAND THAT THEY VOTED NO ON HIS
CONFIRMATION.
THE WOMEN'S MARCH GROUP COUNTS
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND NATIONAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AS
THEIR PREMIER PARTNERS.
BOTH GROUPS HAVE ACTIVELY
OPPOSED KAVANAUGH SINCE HE WAS
ANNOUNCED.
THOSE GROUPS TAKE ON
SIGNIFICANCE BECAUSE OF THEIR
ASSOCIATION WITH GEORGE SOROS.
ACCORDING TO AN EXTENSIVE STUDY
BY THE MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER,
100 OF THE 544 WOMEN'S MARCH
PARTNERS HAVE RECEIVED A TOTAL
OF 246 -- OF MY READING THIS
RIGHT -- 246 MILLION, 637,000,
$217 FROM GEORGE SOROS.
AN ANTIQUE KAVANAUGH PROTEST
FROM GEORGIA WHO LEARNED OF THE
PROTEST FROM A WOMAN'S MARCH
EMAIL, ALONG WITH THE
CONTRIBUTING EDITOR OF THE
SPECTATOR, JEFFREY LORD, AND
PRESIDENT OF CITIZENS UNITED.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ALL ON
TONIGHT.
THIS IS A BIG WEEK FOR
WASHINGTON AND THE COURT AND I
AM SO GLAD YOU CAME ON TONIGHT.
WALK US THROUGH HOW YOU FOUND
OUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING HERE.
>> I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AN
ADVOCATE.
SO THROUGH ADVOCATING AND
VOLUNTEERING WITH THE WOMEN'S
MARCH AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS,
NOT JUST THE WOMEN'S MARCH, YOU
GET THE EMAILS, YOU GET THE
UPDATES, YOU FIND OUT WHAT IS
GOING ON, AND SO WHEN I FOUND
OUT THAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE
HERE IN WASHINGTON, D.C., I CAME
FROM GEORGIA.
>> Laura: SO YOU JUST CAME ON
YOUR OWN TIME, YOU ARE STAYING
IN A HOTEL?
>> I'M STAYING AT A HOTEL.
>> I'M NOT A PAID PROTESTER.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU COME HERE,
DO YOU GET -- DO GET
INSTRUCTIONS, WHERE TO GO?
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
IRONED, GET SAINT STEPHEN'S
CHURCH, NOT TOO FAR FROM HERE.
THE MEET UP PLACES, HOW DOES
THAT WORK?
>> THERE'S MEETINGS AND
TRAININGS THAT LET YOU KNOW WHAT
TO DO, WHAT NOT TO DO.
THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO IT'S VERY ORGANIZED, AND IT'S
VERY GOOD TO BE WITH EVERYONE.
>> Laura: WHAT YOU DO FOR A
LIVING WHEN YOU'RE NOT DOING
THIS?
>> I'M RETIRED, I'M A VETERAN.
>> Laura: FANTASTIC.
WHAT A BRETT KAVANAUGH DO NOT
LIKE?
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT HIM?
>> I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
PERSONALLY AGAINST HIM.
I JUST THINK THIS IS A BAD LOOK
FOR AMERICA.
I THINK THAT HE HAS NOT BEEN
FORTHCOMING.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
ANOTHER CLARENCE THOMAS
SITUATION ON THE HIGHEST --
>> Laura: I CLERKED FOR
CLARENCE THOMAS.
IF YOU KNEW HIM, HE WOULD LOVE
HIM.
HE'S A GREAT PERSON.
>> I'M PRETTY SURE HE IS A GREAT
GUY.
>> Laura: I'M GOING TO
CONVINCE TRIANA.
BY THE TIME THE END OF THE
SEGMENT, I'M CONVINCING YOU
BECAUSE TRIANA IS TOO COOL.
SHE HAS 12 KIDS SHE'S RAISED
WITH HER HUSBAND, EIGHT BOYS --
>> EIGHT BOYS, FOCAL GIRLS.
>> THEY SHOULD TAKE CARE OF HER
HOTEL.
>> Laura: WHAT THE HECK?
TAKE CARE OF TRIANA.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW --
>> Laura: I THINK THEY GOT A
LITTLE HELP FOR THE HOTEL ROOM.
>> GEORGE SOROS, IT'S NOT
SURPRISING.
GEORGE SOROS PAID FOR THE FAKE
DOSSIER.
GLENN SIMPSON AND FUSION GPS.
SO HE'S CONNECTED THROUGHOUT ALL
OF THE LEFT-WING ACTIVITIES IN
THIS COUNTRY AND AROUND THE
WORLD.
IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE, MAYBE
A LITTLE CONSISTENCY FROM THESE
PROTESTERS.
MAYBE THEY CAN GO OUT AND TALK
ABOUT CORY BOOKER AS A GROVER OR
MAYBE THEY CAN TALK ABOUT
KEITH ELLISON BATTERING HIS
GIRLFRIEND OR MAY BE
SENATOR CARPER FROM DELAWARE WHO
BEAT HIS WIFE, MAYBE WE CAN HAVE
A CONVERSATION THAT'S A LOT
BIGGER THAN JUST SOME UNFOUNDED,
QUITE HONESTLY, WITH NO
EVIDENCE, TO BACK IT UP, NO
CORROBORATION, NO WITNESSES,
AGAINST BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THESE SAME DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
ARE SAYING THAT HE IS GUILTY
UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT.
THAT IS NOT HOW WE ARE SUPPOSED
TO DO THIS.
>> Laura: SOME OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.THAT IS BEING DONE FROM
A PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MOVING ON
THIS ISSUE, I THINK THEY ARE
ACTUALLY MAKING INTERESTING
COALITIONS WITH MINORITY GROUPS
AND OTHERS, WHO NORMALLY DON'T
LOOK AT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IN
A VERY CHARITABLE WAY.
BUT PART OF WHAT IS BRINGING
THEM TOGETHER IS THIS IDEA THAT
PROSECUTORS ARE OVERZEALOUS AND
ARE CONVICTING PEOPLE WHO REALLY
DON'T HAVE A SHOT THAT EITHER
DEFENDING THEMSELVES OR
CONVICTING THEM BEFORE THEY HAVE
REALLY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO PUT
ON THE KIND OF EVIDENCE THEY
NEED TO.
SO IT'S INTERESTING THESE GROUPS
ARE TURNING ON --
>> THERE'S A BACKLASH COMING.
>> Laura: HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
JEFFREY LORD, YOU HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN THIS BECAUSE OF
YOUR WORK IN ANOTHER JUDICIAL
CONFIRMATION THAT INVOLVED A
SIMILAR TYPE OF SWARM.
TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> YES, YES.
MY BEST FRIEND FROM COLLEGE'S
JUDGE DE BROOKE SMITH, NOW THE
THIRD CIRCUIT CHIEF JUDGE,
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS.
HE WAS THE REAGAN CHIEF COURT OF
THE WESTERN DISTRICT IN 2001
PART WHEN PRESIDENT BUSH 43
PICKED THEM TO GO TO THE THIRD
CIRCUIT, AND THEY DID
EXACTLY WHAT THEY DID TO ROBERT
BORK AND WHAT THEY ARE DOING
HERE.
THE THING YOU HAVE TO ALWAYS
GAUGE, THE GROUP BEHIND THE
SCENE, FOR EXAMPLE, ONE SENATOR
HAD 21 OF HIS 28 QUESTIONS
SUBMITTED TO JUDGE SMITH THAT I
TRACKED DOWN WHERE WORD FOR WORD
IN SOME CASES, FROM INTERNAL
MEMOS THAT WE GOT A HOLD OF FROM
ONE OF THESE INTEREST GROUPS.
THEY ARE VERY, VERY POWERFUL.
AND THERE WERE 27 OF THEM WHO
ARRANGED -- YOU ORCHESTRATED
AGAINST JUDGE SMITH, AND THEY
GIVE STORIES TO THE PRESS,
"THE WASHINGTON POST,"
PUBLISHED, THEY DO ALL OF THESE
KIND OF THINGS.
IT'S A REAL SERIOUS PROBLEM.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE ARE
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS BASICALLY,
WHAT YOU CAN SEE, THE GROUPS
BEHIND THESE DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
THAT ARE PULLING THE STRINGS,
WHICH THEY ARE DOING.
GEORGE SOROS IS A MATTER OF
FACT.
FOR ONE OF THOSE GROUPS IN 2002.
>> Laura: OPEN SOCIETY
FOUNDATION HAS EIGHT ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
A HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THEY CAN SPEND IT ANYWAY THEY
WANT.
IF THEY WANT TO GIVE MONEY TO
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, NATIONAL
RESOURCE DEFENSE COUNCIL,
WOMEN'S MARCH, HE CAN DO IT.
WE ARE THE REPUBLICANS.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE TO HAVE
THEIR OWN GROUPS.
>> WE ARE.
WE ARE OUTGUNNED.
THEY HAVE A VERY DEDICATED,
GEORGE SOROS --
>> Laura: THEY WANT TO ROCK
THIS PHOTO THE MIDTERMS.
>> ELECTIONS TO HAVE
CONSEQUENCES, AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR PEOPLE TURN
OUT A NOVEMBER.
>> Laura: TRIANA, LAST WORD TO
YOU -- IT MIGHT BE SIGNED
ALREADY BACKFIRING.
TRIANA, WHAT DO YOU HOPE TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH YOUR TIME HERE?
>> I HOPE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT HE
RECEIVES A "NO" VOTE.
I UNDERSTAND YOU SAY POOR BRETT
BUT WHAT ABOUT DR. FORD?
WHAT ABOUT MS. RAMIREZ --
>> SHE WILL GET HER OPPORTUNITY
ON THURSDAY.
>> THAT IS ALL WE ARE ASKING
FOR, THAT AN ACCURATE FBI
INVESTIGATION BE CONDUCTED,
MR. KAVANAUGH HAS NOT BEEN
FORTHCOMING --
>> Laura: WHAT YOU MEAN HE'S
NOT BEEN FORTHCOMING?
>> FOR EXAMPLE, HE'S NOT BEEN
FORTHCOMING WITH EVERYTHING
ABOUT HIS PAST.
>> Laura: HE'S BEEN IN PUBLIC
SERVICE FOR ALMOST THREE DECADE
DECADES.
>> SIX BACK ON.
>> THAT'S A PROBLEM.
>> Laura: THAT'S A PROBLEM?
>> IF YOU ARE A JUDGE, WOULDN'T
YOU WANT TO SEE THE EVIDENCE?
WHAT DID YOU WANT TO HEAR ALL
SIDES?
>> Laura: DO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE DOING 36 YEARS AGO?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HECK I WAS
DOING.
>> I ACTUALLY DO.
I KNOW WHAT I WAS DOING 36 YEARS
AGO.
I WAS A CHILD MODEL FOR A
COMPANY --
>> Laura: BUT IF SOMEONE COMES
ALONG AND SAID, YOU DID THIS,
YOU ARE A CHILD MODEL, YOU DID
THIS AND YOU ARE LIKE, I KNOW, I
DIDN'T.
NO ONE IS CORROBORATING THE
PERSON ACCUSING YOU.
WHERE TO GO TO GET YOUR GOOD
NAME BACK?
YOU DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
>> BY CANDY ASKED INVESTIGATION
IN ORDER TO CLEAR HIS NAME?
>> THAT'S NOT THE FBI'S JOB.
WE LEARNED THAT FROM
CLARENCE THOMAS.
THAT VIDEO BY JOE BIDEN.